[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to our construction project
we're about to have our hundred and
seventy fifth year and we're gonna
dedicate a beautiful chapel and
everywhere around the campus you see
change although the changes are real and
serious they're superficial because the
deeper thing is the same the college was
founded for four things freedom faith
and learning and character if you read
the 1844 document in beautiful language
that's what it says
the seniors today are to be marked an
educated person through a difficult
curriculum but you chose knowing it was
harder than most this college is all
about getting what's right what's wrong
what's honor
what's integrity what's virtue when it's
all said and done they're gonna say
something about us this College is
giving you the foundation to fill that
space in the right and proper way so
make it count over the past four years
we've been formed molded pulled
stretched and shaped we have been poured
into with the intended purpose that
after today we will pour into others
what we've gleaned from this place and
while it may seem like we're each taking
different roads after graduation we're
really not on different paths at all we
are each stewards of what we now hold
talents skills
character and knowledge of what is
beautiful and good it is our duty to use
these for God's glory
[Applause]